[MUSIC PLAYING]
VAIDEESWARAN
SETHURAMAN: Divum has
been started by me and Sree.
Sree is my wife.
She carries a lot of
passion for startups,
and I carry a lot of
passion for technology.
We provide services in the areas
of design, cloud, and mobile.
Divum Labs was set up to build
a single primary product called
Terraa.
Terraa is an online
grocery mobile application.
It's available on both
iPhone and Android.
People can browse hundreds of
products available over there,
and they can place an order.
So when we were brainstorming
about Terraa last year,
we looked at the
overall industry
Several players were
upcoming in the grocery
space, and we [INAUDIBLE]
a lot of problems
to be solved in this area.
That's where the Google
Developer Agency Program
helped a lot in terms
of bringing awareness
of what are the best practices.
VISHNU GOVINDASAMI: The
two major challenges
that were thrown to
the Terraaa tech team
was scalability and
building dataset.
KRISHNA SL: We have
been constantly looking
for opportunities
to work with Google.
We were totally
convinced of using
Google Stack right from
backend, the frontend,
and our analytics.
And the programs like
Google Developer Agency
was the right fit
to bridge this gap.
And the support from Google
when we hit roadblocks
was tremendous.
VISHNU GOVINDASAMI:
When the opportunity
was presented by the Google
Developer Agency Program
to meet the Firebase
team, we really got
to know all how deeply
the Firebase is also
integrated with the App Engine.
And it was easy for us
to make the communication
between these two platforms.
KRISHNA SL: App Engine with
the combination of DataStore
was the best possible option
for us to scale [INAUDIBLE]
from day one.
With the concept of
Firebase that we had,
we had seamless synchronization
of inventory, cart,
and location tracking
of the drivers.
VISHNU GOVINDASAMI:
Three major advantages
of the Developer
Agency Program--
first one is the online training
courses that they provided us.
Second is the material design
training that they provided us.
And third one is all
the opportunities
that they provided us to
meet the Firebase core team.
VAIDEESWARAN
SETHURAMAN: Sree and me
used to spend a lot of hours
and hours discussing technology.
So both of us, we always
want to do something crazy,
we want to adapt all the
technologies at once.
That's where Google
Developer Agency
Program came at the right time.
And they are
continuously working
towards building disruptive
technologies and disruptive
solutions.
Terraa make motivation
for us to work.
VISHNU GOVINDASAMI: We expect
a lot more training coming up,
and also a lot more insights
into the latest technologies.
We are really looking forward
to continuing this relationship.
[MUSIC PLAYING]